the miami dolphins unexpectedly making a
playoff run at three and three through
six games so everything's fine ryan
fitzpatrick has been fit's magic there's
no reason to screw anything up don't
tinker with the problem if it ain't
broke don't fix it throw any other
cliches we want on top of the pile
oh wait
two tongue of iloa is replacing fits
magic as the starting quarterback i've
got some thoughts on this shereen i'm
gonna defer to you i've got some
thoughts on why they're doing what
they're doing and whether they should be
doing it but i'm very curious what do
you think about the move from
fitzpatrick to the fifth overall pick in
the draft
well mike on the one hand it's very
surprising because they've won two games
in a row and ryan fitzpatrick has done
absolutely nothing to lose this job he's
completing over 70 of his passes he's
thrown for over 1500 yards 10 touchdowns
he's played well enough for them to win
and be where they are and so if you're
just looking at this season you keep
ryan fitzpatrick in there and you let
him play but on the other hand
the the bye week is this week and they
have a chance to give him two weeks of
practice to come back to say you're
going to be our starting quarterback so
from that standpoint it really makes a
ton of sense and look to have a coach
who you know is not going to get fired
after this season he can do this he can
let the young guy play and think about
the future and not think about saving
his job this year
here's the way i look at it very simply
i'm going to use the metaphor that i can
relate to first and then get into more
of the football analysis
ryan fitzpatrick lost this job the
moment that the dolphins used the fifth
overall pick to take tuatanga vialoa and
here here's the the example that maybe
some can relate to
we live kind of on the edge of
civilization so every once in a while a
mouse gets in the house
and my wife and my son sometimes are
like well how do we get the mouse out
without killing it it's like hang on
the mouse died the moment it came into
the house the question is
when does the mouse actually become dead
so
it's either going to be through the trap
in the basement or the trap in the
garage or the and we have a humane trap
that we that we also use so i'm i'm
being a little extreme and graphic with
my metaphor but the point is this
this was inevitable when tuatanga viloa
was picked by the dolphins and i've been
saying all along the sooner they throw
him out there the sooner he gets
prepared to be competitive at some point
down the road now i understand patrick
mahomes saddled almost all the 2017
season and the chiefs made it to the
playoffs that year and he played one
game and he was great the next year but
you know what
i still submit that if they had switched
to my homes halfway through the season
when the offense was sputtering they may
have been even better in 2017. we may
have all been deprived of one hell of an
impressive playoff run from this rookie
quarterback who would have come in and
done spectacular things so i'm not
saying what the chiefs did was right it
worked but it may have worked even
better in 2017. i think the sooner you
get the guy out there on the field the
better it is this isn't about ryan
fitzpatrick this is about tuatanga viloa
is ready and
it was inevitable he was going to be
ready and playing at some point this
year ideally once they made him the
fifth overall pick and the thing about
fitzpatrick
you have to know
when
fitzmagic is going to become fits tragic
because we know what's going to happen
and who better to know that it may be
coming than the coaching staff that sees
him every single day and it's all about
picking the right time to make that
switch it's rocky balboa switching back
to southpaw the dolphins think that this
is the time to do it because they're in
a position to be competitive and if they
can get an upgrade from tonga by low and
they got two weeks to get him ready
because their buy got moved to this week
and they got the rams on the other side
good luck to uh welcome to the nfl tour
here's aaron donald but
this is something that actually can help
propel the dolphins into postseason
contention instead of let's see how it
plays out with ryan fitzpatrick this
year he's earned the right to try to get
to the playoffs not baloney baloney they
can put two in get him valuable reps and
maybe turn this unexpected season of
postseason contention into a playoff
birth shireen
and no one better to groom to uh than
ryan fitzpatrick and you saw when tua
came into the game on sunday
ryan fitzpatrick was waving the towel
and trying to get the small crowd that
was there up on their feet and cheering
him there is going to be no bigger
supporter of tour than ryan fitzpatrick
he will be there supporting him helping
him in whatever way he needs and that's
terrific and mike let's let's review
what the other two rookie quarterbacks
have done one drafted obviously before
two and one drafted after tua so day one
the bengals named joe burrow the
starting quarterback right he come out
comes out plays all season and has
played well i think we would all agree
the other one justin herbert was not
supposed to start in for the chargers
and he didn't in the first game and then
suddenly you have a doctor gone wild who
sticks a needle in the wrong place and
tyrod taylor who by the way has not yet
come back and all of a sudden justin
herbert your starter goes in plays well
wins the job when tyra taylor was
supposed to go back and get the job how
much do you think that the success of
those other two quarterbacks may be sped
up this process or were they always
looking at the bye week
i think that when you see the other two
guys who were taking one five spots
before 201 right after tour when you see
those guys play and thrive i think that
results potentially in pressure from the
top of the organization working its way
down the ladder and the questions are
coming and when are we going to get to
an end and when is tua going to be ready
the belief in league circles is that
tuatanga viloa was an owner's draft pick
and that happens we know that happens
the owners don't come out and say it
because they don't want to come off as
meddling but there are times when the
owner makes it known what he wants and
one of the privileges of being a
billionaire is you don't have to give a
direct order you just have to be
a little bit subtle and the people who
are employed by you who would very much
like to continue to be employed by you
will understand the example i used when
the browns took johnny manziel in the
first round back in 2014. jimmy haslam
doesn't have to walk in the door and say
order a bag of snickers all he has to
say is i like that candy what's that
candy called snickers i really like that
then the next thing you know snickers
are going to be falling out of every
drawer and cabinet in the facility if
people know what's good for them so you
don't have to come out and say it and if
you're stephen ross you don't have to
come out and say put him on the field
all it takes is one well-placed question
and
chris greer the gm gets the message and
coach brian flores gets the message and
they get him ready and he's good to go
and they see what happens so i don't
know whose decision this ultimately is
and it's not like ross is ever going to
say he made the call or initiated it but
the time had come to find out what he
has because you know what shireen
statistically
there's a chance he's the best
now look hey maybe all three of the guys
taking one five and six overall are
going to become franchise quarterbacks
pro bowlers hall of famers best to ever
play the game but history tells us that
there's a good chance one of them may
not be very good now 2004 it worked out
well with eli manning and phillip rivers
and ben roethlisberger taking in the
first 11. but i'd become very antsy if
i'm the dolphin seeing that the other
two guys look like the real deal i want
to see if our guy is as well especially
because the guy we passed on is looking
pretty damn good in justin herbert
what i find interesting mike is two
weeks ago
tua didn't get in the game to a blowout
late and they asked brian flores about
it and he says i don't see any point in
putting him in late i don't know what
point that serves so you kept fast
forward to this week same situation and
they put tua in the game and he throws
two passes and he looked
good for the two passes he threw and
what he did in the short time he was in
there but i'm curious if something
changed
in the last week where we're not going
to put him in mop up duty and get him
any snaps and all of a sudden yes we're
go we are going to put him in mop up
duty and at least get some of those
nerves out so he has some snaps and
knows what to expect i did find that
very interesting and curious that that
it was almost the same situation two
weeks in a row in a different response
and i think it's exciting that we're
going to see what tua has
one way or another we're going to find
out he's going to and that's the thing
with no pre-season you know you can't
tell much from the two snaps from last
week from with no preseason he gets the
start does he pass the eyeball test does
he belong how does he hold up can he
stay healthy that's the big question
because he had three lower body injuries
in his three seasons at alabama and one
of the concerns after he had the hip
fracture last year was can he stay
healthy at the nfl level we'll find out
he's going to have to avoid contact that
is job number one and that's something
he didn't do at
alabama hi i'm mike tarico and thanks
for watching make sure to hit subscribe
for the latest news and highlights from
nbc sports